CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Murrow was acting
and deputy director of the CIA good
morning morning we know the suspects
parents were Libyan immigrants and that
he had ties to Isis what stands out to
you about him the fact that he traveled
frequently to Libya we know that Isis is
in Libya once had a stronghold in Libya
so it's possible that he had Isis
contacts there it's also possible that
he traveled to Syria
they're still trying to figure that out
so I think that's what's important he
may have come into contact with Isis so
this may be more of an Isis directed
attack than just a lone wolf self
radicalized attack from behind the
scenes when they say raise the threat
level as they have what does that
exactly mean so there's there's five
threat levels in the UK since 2014
they've been at the second highest level
because of all the Isis activity what
they did yesterday was to raise it to
the highest level and the reason they
did that is because they're not 100%
sure that this guy did not act with a
bigger group that he was part of a
bigger Network and until they figure
that out it's best to assume that he was
and therefore that more attacks might be
coming we'll see over the next couple
days whether he was part of a network or
not and what it means when they when
when they raise it to the highest level
is that the military replaces the police
in some of the most vulnerable areas so
that's what will actually change on the
street you know one of the reasons I
think the story is so painful and
egregious is that many of the victims
were young girls and the bomber had to
know that before he went in are they
trying to terrify people to the point to
say we will take your children is that
the message so Isis has said from the
very beginning that women and children
are part of the target set on that they
don't make a distinction between men
women and children and I think that's
what we saw here so I'm not sure he
targeted because they were young
children but he didn't care that they
were on the battlefield in both Iraq and
Syria we're seeing gains against Isis
but this kind of attack mean that
they're strong and that they're
continuing to be a huge threat so we are
making significant gains Mosul will fall
probably in the next several weeks Raqqa
possibly by the end of the year but
what's happening is I think two things
one is Isis is saying to its followers
around the world don't come to Iraq and
Syria anymore conduct attacks for us
where you live so that's becoming a
stronger message that may have played a
role here and then second is is is 7,000
people from Western Europe went to fight
in Iraq and Syria 2,000 have come home
already some have died on the
battlefield but as they get squeezed
more and more in Mosul and Raqqa more
and more are going to come home and that
actually raises the threat level you had
to have watched former CIA director
Brennan's testimony yesterday what's
your takeaway from that so what what
struck me Charlie on is that the US
government was concerned enough last
summer about Russian interference in the
election that they had the CIA director
make contact with his Russian
counterpart and tell them to stop and
the Russians clearly didn't so my
question is what did the Obama
administration do after that after they
learned that the warning had fallen on
deaf ears they did nothing it appears
they did nothing Michael Morell thank
you as always welcome